which is going to war and no I don't
mean they're doing something about the
inconsistent bans policy or the scam
streams or people looping vod's with
drops to get views note which has found
a far more important enemy to tackle
twitch is going to war against simps
all right so normally this is the part
of the video where I would tell you guys
to you know sub to the channel and you
should definitely still do that if you
haven't already but I also wanted to let
you know that we are now streaming on
Twitch you can head over to twitch.tv
slash the score esports throw us a
follow soon you'll able to sub to us and
I don't know maybe sim for the channel
or something okay so over the last
couple of weeks twitch has gone to work
deleting a lot of streamers emotes that
include or mention the word
sim fed simp was removed from my emotes
for targeted a harassment and bullying
very unfortunate one of my favorite
emotes but we never I mean my community
never used it with ill intent it was
mostly banter a few streamers have
already been hit by this and many people
who are submitting symptoms emotes are
getting those emos rejected which is
saying that these emotes fall under the
disallowed content section of their
Terms of Service because they include
target harassment or bullying so this is
all obviously kind of weird go tacos
Nathan Grayson who reported on the story
a few weeks ago spoke to several twitch
streamers who had their emotes either
removed or rejected and they all pretty
much said the same thing those emotes
were harmless so if they're harmless
why is twitch banning these emotes why
is twitch going in on Sims well the word
simp has a long and complicated history
you've definitely seen it crop up online
more and more over the last few months
and at this point it's escape the
internet entirely simp has its roots in
african-american vernacular English
where it kind of means what it means on
the Internet today sort of basically
simple is used to call out men who spent
a lot of time and money on women who
didn't want them and never would and it
was common enough that it was even used
in a three 6 mafia's on appeal and yes
that is literally the only lyric of that
song we can play on YouTube without
getting demonetised anyways a couple of
decades passed and eventually sim kind
of took on a different meaning
at some point over the last couple of
years in cells decided to take the word
simp and apply it to anyone who was ever
nice to any woman ever so basically like
how everyone is a white knight to
but you shouldn't feel bad for using the
word simp just because of one [ __ ] up
chapter in the words history at this
point it's just a meme it's funny to
call yourself a sim for having like a
favorite anime character people are
simpler their girlfriends now the word
is harmless and honestly pretty funny
except that there are still some people
out there who want to use it as an
insult
look I'm personally not a huge fan of
using the word simp as an insult I think
trying to imply that men who are nice to
women are somehow bad is kinda
ridiculous but the fact that I just said
all that means the entire comments
section will be calling me a sin so
there's no winning the meme is too
powerful so all that said it does kind
of make sense white which is against
simps I guess the word does have a
[ __ ] up history and it can be used as
an insult even if most of the emos -
twitches removing or rejecting are
harmless and just part of the mean but
the issue here isn't that twitch is
banning some harmless emotes the issue
is that twitch has way bigger things to
deal with right now and they're spending
their time on harmless emotes over the
last few months twitch has come under
fire for a completely inconsistent
banning policy that has seen some of
their biggest names get away with things
that smaller streamers would be perma
banned for and targeted harassment and
chat that has gotten completely out of
control
a big reason of why twitches rules are
so easily Advent is that they're
insanely ambiguous something can be
against the rules as they're written but
when a streamer gets away with doing it
it's really against the rules a few
weeks ago illinit II had a wardrobe
malfunction on her stream which didn't
do something immediately so she
basically suspended herself taking three
days off streaming then the next day
which actually suspended hurt themselves
was it because she actually did
something wrong was it because people
were complaining too much was it because
the case just got too big to ignore
we'll never know the rules just aren't
hard and fast personally I think it's
cuz all twitch can do is react banner
bull stuff happens on their platform
every single day but they just can't
notice everything so if enough people
complain about something that's was
gonna spur them into action
and this kind of stuff isn't just
happening now it's been happening for a
long time last year we did a video about
two streamers who got banned for
something that happened years before now
twitch has just launched a Safety
Advisory Council to help mitigate some
of the issues they've been having with
inconsistent moderation but while I
think that's a good idea the issue is
that twitch is still making the calls
here for all of twitches talked about
listening to their community having
these voices on their council and even
listening to streamers who are just
talking about things on their own stream
those people aren't the ones making
decisions about who should be banned
what should be allowed on stream twitch
is doing that twitch makes every single
decision and right now when things are
at their most ambiguous their messiest
which chose to go to war against the
Sims
that's [ __ ] that's that's classic
Bevin it's actually weird every time you
look at them and I see him in sepia tone
that Bevin wasn't actually in full color
until he was 18 he was black and white
before then